would you go down son then you want to
know i would love to yeah i'm dying too
i mean i'm dying to go to japan as a
whole as i'm sure every guest you've had
you haven't been yet right i think
you're the most obsessed with your fan
of any of the guests yeah yeah well you
applied for the jet program i did and i
got declined in record pace why did you
why did you get declined i don't know i
thought it was i mean i know that i know
the selection process is really tough
yeah yeah i thought they left anyone on
there
jet selection is actually but they let
crisco so it can't be like that
i mean
it was it was very different all those
years ago
it's like our economy isn't shameful
no when i applied i went to like a whole
seminar because i graduated from arizona
state
and uh which which is a university where
they actually check your heartbeat and
they let you in yeah uh and i got a
degree in english and journalism right
and uh and i had recently broke up my
girlfriend uh and i was like you know at
that pivotal point where i'm like what
do i do with my life yeah i was like
[ __ ] it i'll go to japan yeah uh and i
applied and i thought i was a standout
and they're like no shot and i was like
oh
and like in preparation for it that's i
think what i originally like that's
where i found chris and i was like okay
i have to watch abroad in japan videos
because i have to know the seven things
i can't do in japan
i would hate to do those
uh and then i just i literally continued
to watch it as if i'm applying every
year right right even though i have no
ability to go to japan yeah right yeah
you've never been to japan never know
yeah because i remember you were saying
uh like before your twitch channel
popped off you used to watching a lot of
like japan-based creators and like
japan-based like twitch streamers and
stuff like that first guy sub two was
retro gaijin yeah oh damn he was just
he's just a dude from like ohio who
lives in i think tokyo now uh and i
watched him back in the day like seven
years ago and he just used to play smash
4 which is my favorite game back then
too and i was like okay japan cool smash
cool combo right right uh and yeah and
so it's like i'm still
i still watch him i watch pretty much
every japan creator i've seen them at
some point right you know uh so i think
i'm going in
not disillusioned not thinking anime
will rain down from the skies and pretty
aware of everything or subtitles yeah
well wait
let's do something right
after the olympics yeah yeah uh and i i
i still think it'll be really tight yeah
yeah yeah you'll love it is there
anything in particular you want to do
there now because like it seems like out
of every creator you've
you've been in like indirectly involved
in the japanese youtube community just
because you consume so much of it yeah i
think because of that it that will
influence a lot of what i do like i want
to go to dogen's place because it seems
so tight oh yeah yeah i really want to
go as well uh and he offered because i i
hit him that right after he got i hit
him with that sly like nice house
be ashamed you didn't have someone in
there filling it up
that guest room looks awfully empty yeah
exactly
uh oh and like i like all the classics
like okinawa i want to go to aomori
because that seems tight as [ __ ] yeah uh
and yeah when i go i think i'll go for a
month and i'll just live there for a
month yeah
don't go during the summer months though
no yeah yeah it seems brain dead to go
yeah
i hate being here and it's probably
worse than here like it's ten times less
than here yeah it's here but just up the
humidity by ninety percent yeah yeah
which is miserable it is because it
sucks here like you go outside it's 95
uv's like a 10 you're burning instantly
i think i think yesterday was like 110
120 something like that yeah which is
[ __ ] disgusting yeah that's the time
when we don't leave our houses like
right yeah i think the tokyo i got i saw
an article was like tokyo government was
asking people to not leave their lights
on after three or something because
they're they're so short electricity
powering all the ac yeah yeah the [ __ ]
dudes yeah mcconnell has this like ac on
24 7.
it's running right now just waiting for
him to come back
i want to keep it
it's more expensive to turn it on and
off yeah exactly
yeah i mean i'm i i get like heat stroke
and i faint and [ __ ] if it's too hot so
like i pretty much should have it on all
the time
during the summer especially it's brutal
yeah there's a lot of people who like
pass out and die from the heat strokes
whales we don't have that we don't know
i don't have that in the states either i
mean like unless someone's like hiking
on the appalachian trail and then it's
like or you're in arizona which like you
decided to live there your fault
you're from new hampshire right yes is
that pretty cool is that nice it gets
humid and like muggy but it gets like
you know not too bad oh okay in terms of
temperature what is new hampshire famous
for
we have one of the worst presidents of
all time franklin pierce who committed
genocide amongst native americans
and also a cool mountain oh okay well
they kind of found it
really cool
maybe you start off at the mountain you
know yeah it was called old man on the
mountain and it was just a mountain that
looked like it had a face on it and then
it fell
because the face was so heavy so now
it's just a mountain yeah and now it's
just like a normal mountain but we still
call it that right when we drive by
we're like it was our 911.
never forget baby
i like how that's the that's the
equivalence for americans like is it a
bad thing it's it's it's the 911 yeah
it's the you know that is the worst
thing that could happen
[Music]
nothing worse has ever happened no in
the history
uh yeah that's that's it it's a small
small state and you're you're the
biggest youtuber in your school right no
i know yeah [ __ ] you
are you nuts i i went to a school at
hollis brooklyn they had to combine two
towns and our graduating class was like
relatively small it's like 200 people uh
and i'm not the biggest youtuber who
graduated from that school i sort of
asked you that because there's this
annoying least big successful fortnight
youtuber who's like mr top five
it'll be like top five fortnight
glitches in season eight act three pro
prague two like whatever yeah it's like
four or five million catching up to that
come on i'll get there that's like five
and by then he'll find he'll be on the
roblox high dude
he's the emmy he's like he's like dude
went to the same school and i i don't
have the heart to message him back
because all i feel is angered towards
you wait don't talk to me
i'm like no
he's also younger than me oh yeah i was
gonna ask are you like a senior class or
was that i'm older than him
yeah so i like i'm supposed to be cooler
i'm i was a senior you were a freshman
so
i'm the biggest youtuber from my school
oh yeah of the 20. are you the biggest
welsh youtuber
no i think there's someone who did like
fifa or something rolled idiot
you're the biggest youtuber from your
school i mean i am i mean i would be the
biggest youtuber in my city until
[ __ ] pewdiepie moved here
but even then jack we got jacksepticeye
there yeah you know i i got a ways to
catch up but they came into my territory
you know i feel like
yeah you know i i was like born and
raised there now if by that metric i
wouldn't be the biggest youtuber in the
world i don't live there anymore but
native you know are you native to
brighton yeah yeah i was born and raised
in brighton yeah that's like isn't that
like an amazing town to be like raised
in it's like beautiful right yeah yeah i
mean right like now it is it wasn't even
like a city when i was like growing up
there um it was just like a small town
and then suddenly it became i guess now
like the san francisco i guess of the uk
yeah now it's like the youtube hub of
the uk yeah everyone lives there yeah
yeah yeah every consumer i've met yeah
either you go to london and like you
hate life or whatever yeah uh or you
move to brighton and just have a great
time because it's just good vibes what
can i say it'll be well soon the whales
will be the hub well
[Music]
though you're saying it like you like
them too much
but they're nice
cheap houses
yeah i imagine cheaper than here way
cheaper i'll give you that bro
anything's cheaper than here you did
that uh that uh one video it was like uh
what can you get for like a million
dollars did you do whales no
i did like well i did like the
clickbaity ones
japan gets clicks america gets clicks
clicks dude welsh flagged
the one welsh person trying to get like
welsh culture up there i'm trying my
best dude i'm trying to then they won't
do it for some reason the welsh board of
marketing or whatever the [ __ ] is not
doing anything you could probably like
say hey i want to start a channel with
you guys you pay for it all and you just
teach welsh lessons once a week who
would i talk to who's the [ __ ] guy
you like upload youtube you talk to the
welsh guy i don't know there's like
seven
it's like seven of us dude just go do
you know any other welsh youtubers
actually i don't think about it
no
no not at all
there's no one can understand them you
know that i think i told about the story
there was a there was this tv show uh
that was produced by like the because
the wet wells has their own like tv uh i
don't know [ __ ] what do you call
network syndicate yeah and they had this
documentary which was like about
successful welsh youtubers and i was so
pissed off they didn't ask me
you weren't on it no because they they
had got someone who had like 10 000 subs
i i'm not like a guy who's like i don't
give a [ __ ] about numbers but at that
one time i was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
i would have said yes they didn't even
reach out to me wait were you living in
wales at the time though no but that's
even more that's probably why there's
more hype though come see me in japan
dude from wales that's awesome like it's
a that's a success story your accent's
not thick enough for them anymore i
could have brought it back
so you know i just make these videos in
japan you see and i i'm going around and
i talk to the natives
and we make these fun videos like i
would have done it whatever they wanted
i would have done it i would have been
flexing anything i was so annoyed they
didn't ask me and i'm like yeah i just
thought come on you even there's there's
more than people with 10 thousand subs
there's someone else you could have gone
you should bring them up and be like do
you know who i am
well i think that's where like it was
just the production company we're just
like yeah we found this guy he seems to
be doing something well
it's good enough like followed there's
probably clickbait they probably found
the guy and then they were like oh we'll
make this segment yeah not like we'll
make the segment we'll find the guy yeah
and the person who was the youtuber had
like a full-time job as well and i'm
like that's it it's like what the [ __ ]
is the point of this
it's not even their main stick it's like
just home videos
i'm just like come on guys what do you
what do they have in wales is that a
president uh we do have a pro we have a
yeah prime minister prime minister yeah
be that go be that
i don't think it's that easy
how many people live in wales
three million
england is like 60 million i mean yeah
it's i know it's not that big but it's
like it's bigger than i thought it'd be
yeah well it's more than northern
ireland so we're not the not the
smallest right hey you're not isle of
man
well yo he's got that who wants to be
the island exactly yeah i mean chris
says chris says it's nice though
yeah yeah i thought it's really good i
haven't been myself